what's happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch Black Mirror season
6 episode 3. it's the one with Aaron Paul I'm
excited John how are you feeling I could not
be giddier for Aaron Paul on Black Mirror
he was actually I believe a voice in the on
that Rift on Star Trek with Jesse Clemons I'm
number six and I believe he had a voice there
that's a fun fact for you I'll leave a like
on this video that would mean the world also
subscribe click the notification Bell because we
are getting through these episodes oh it's one
more thing oh yes full interaction watch along
where you sync it with their own copy of Black
Mirror available for a super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page thank you to all who
have been joining so far we've been getting
so many pledge encumbersome movie reactions
and many of you have joined us for Black Mirror
alone so thank you guys they also cover several
things exclusive over there with rational Heights
and watch alongs included let's watch this show
sweetheart I'm gonna scratch your
nose try to go back Josh partner damn
it's cool to see him here I loved his work
in Westworld oh rest in peace rest in peace
hey hey is that Amora well Kate not Amara the
name hey Mara you're David Ross I believe I
am it's an honor to meet you sir oh my God
such an honor you're the porn star David Rose
on the smut theater there are you like like
it's a kind of sleep The Human Experience
the survival of the human body of life that's
really Central to the mission she's so tired whoa
so he's not actually here our Lord heavenly
father bless us and these thy gifts which
we take from thy Bountiful goodness through
Jesus Christ Our Lord amen is he also in space
I guess it's safe to assume are these like
avatars oh and it's a clear win for Lily
nice parking job people smoking
reefer in that van hippies
what passion
leave the room John yeah sorry I have
a duty to attend to [Laughter] have fun
that's why this episode's so long
this goes on for at least 10 minutes
sorry sweetheart I gotta go this Josh Arnett
is unusually good looking yeah come again sorry
I have to go
such distance between them and uh juxtaposing
of the city life and the country life
oh it's interesting they said it
in the past yeah like the height
of the Space Race too there is
a crack in the silver coating
ah cool [Music]
this music cue is like Halloween
it's just them two [Music]
nope how's the new home it's good Henry liking
the country air he'll grow into it and Lana
Cape Ann gonna be Cosmopolitan enough for
her fish Island when's our next physical
Friday I'll see you Friday
have a good week you too
weekend astronauts Josh Hardin it's evolved
to have a bit of a Brad Pitt thing about him
oh yeah good call now is is it the Clone in space
you know what I mean yeah so why wouldn't you
just put the Clone in space just let it be there
all day yeah maybe we should have a little party
I don't know be good for Henry to meet
some local kids we'll see that means no
arms perfectly
hop into your third body in the kitchen how many
chairs do you have in this house get out of my
house oh we've met the machine man is this the
Manson people Kappa oh this is Sigma Theta and
that's Epsilon we are Greeks you're in my house
indeed we are talking nothing has to happen
No Stranger the crowd get down because Casey at
the bathroom Casey at the bats good reference
and the Mighty Casey has struck out get
him in position come on lay his arm out
whoa let's see what's inside your hand is
he a cyborg that is a tough steak [Music]
oh
you are nothing natural my friend Sigma
give me your hammer Theta get his family no
try to work out where you are
what
oh no he's gonna need to get back home
oh no please not my children please we
just want to find out who else is a
machine Mr Bunny freaks we're real
blood real blood and your kids are real
yeah I'm sorry to report that's immaterial
man sleeps in the sky and you share
your bed with this abomination
you don't actually care about that divine
nature must have a cost or what will become
of us all you and yes the children Wowzer with
his heart screaming a million miles above us
insanely disturbing
wow
is very very disturbing cruel
hello what the hell are you saying
oh man he's trapped up there now do you love a
paranoid Space movie Leave Me Alone I'm so sorry
watch your back man he told me to
get out spoke to ground control and
Holland says she's sleeping baby I'll
be in shock what if he hijacks his body
he'll get revenge
he protected natural order I ride to him by
step they comfort me paying attention yeah
yeah I'm real afraid he's gonna try and like
hijack his family share the body yeah hey
right
foreign
okay
sure this is very fascinating
yeah ominous the man is lost
I can't reach him and I don't know what to do
let's read in Valley of the Dolls what if you
let him use your link as in just for an hour
yeah okay feels a breeze on his face oh man
I don't know sleep with her yeah know the
Comforts of a loving wife drive to California
how would you feel about using my link
would you like that I think I'd like that
very much oh this is gonna be terrible
no good deed goes unpunished
foreign
Paul and his wife are distant yeah he's gonna take
his entire life opening of this Josh Hartnett and
his wife were very intimate he's just gonna smell
the air and go back up it's all it's gonna be
would you like to see the forest yes
that is beautiful
this is my favorite spot I wonder if
she's ever showed the actual Cliff this
you're so clear I've forgotten
damn that looks like a real caterpillar wow this
is like true sci-fi this is like Terence Malek
damn this [__] is so
haunting yeah like at its core
oh
this is beautiful yeah like
gut wrenching but beautiful
he's totally banging my wife
so uh can I get my replica back
oh
your place it's beautiful your
wife hot hotter than my old wife
yep I hope it's Patrick obsessive One Taste oh boy
I got like 15 different emotions
running through me at once yeah
lost and uncomfortable scared and hopeful a
little touched seems a little lighter now a
poor man he wept like a child in front of you
what did you do not much what could I even say
she enjoyed her time with him yeah that's
probably the first time she's felt anything
not strong in years you did this for memory if I
had this down there I would hang it on the wall
you know I could arrange that maybe
get me a canvas and some oils I could
paint you something like this for
your home like a thank you gift
you'd have to let me use your replica again you
might not want to do that drawing helps no matter
how long would a painting take for a little while
obviously six weeks really can't rush art you know
one hour once a week while I'm doing the physical
skin set up his things up in the barn there
clearly it has been on his mind are you gonna
explain this to your kids the kids don't have
to know but he's gonna be like living out there
half the time just one hour a week that's fair
Daddy needs his barn time God there's just so
much pain in this episode are you finding that
Valley of the Dolls can't say I'm crazy about
it my goodness it's trashy a guilty pleasure yes
you like sci-fi can't say I've tried it
think of a few recommendations for you
I'd like that and if it's getting oh man why
don't you pick up a copy of the Kama Sutra
oh no
no dog you
oh yeah you want to go back to that Barn
this feels like old school black beer yeah
[Music] every time yeah
[Music]
she's drawn to him yeah he's
everything she wishes Cliff was
[Music]
this is so bad oh when will you paint me
have you done much painting come
over here I'll guide your hand
here let me just try to add
a little to the tree there
guide her grab her hand yes come
on show her how to stroke the brush
uh ditto totally see this coming
not cheating if it's the same body
damn shake hands he's getting too
used to this painting's looking good
[Laughter] um special of that bush yeah
that one leaf man so much character
there it is oh there it is no I
mean his reality is so painful
that this Escape is everything he needs right
now everything okay do you have any linseed oil
I run out I know that struggle is there a hardware
store in town there's Mitchell's they'll be open
you think Cliff would mind would
borrow his car we borrow his car
I thought you'd never ask
the location is a production value are
well thought out on this episode man yeah
hey I want to check the bookstore
out a moment you want to come sure
I'm also feeling in the mood for oysters you want
to come if you like it are you Cliff Stanfield
yes yes I was so sorry to hear about
what happened with your co-pilot
such a terrible thing no no dose
of reality no how is he doing
he's holding on we really ought to be going he
gonna go Haywire you okay uh oh the comforting
tense
now
yep
any time now it's oddly familiar for her
must be confusing for her yes is is that
you added a mini your mind here
Beyond the Sea
it's popular this is the 60s when people
especially sucked at communicating about
their emotions yeah it's all yeah it's like
all I wanted is like Cliff open up Jesus
in some ways you're worse off than
the other guy oh she looks so happy uh
oh yep here it comes [Music]
And So It Begins busting out the old Playbook
must feel like she's not cheating
it's so confusing must be so confusing
he looked at her like what
he won't know yes
no oh you confused me work your way into my
home wearing my husband like a suit that man
wow
I know the way you look at me
at you look at yourself dude that man lets you
borrow him yup to borrow his whole life oh right
oh now you've done a kid
Henry you should go no I don't think so David
says Henry wrecked his painting he hit him he
gave him a little smack upside the head ugh 60s
get out of coming remember when he burned a hole
in the car seat I wailed on him plenty right
here in this room the boy needs keeping in line
it's feeling bad for you David wants to finish
the painting goddamn painting I know let's just
let him finish the painting
two more visits tops and then
I will come up with something you'll come
up dead your things are set up in the barn
a please I'm taking Henry to the pool even let him
hit the kid it's crazy 60s man the different time
find the sketch all this time
he's expected his privacy yeah
foreign
did she actually pose for that uh I don't think so
you know he knows a figure from memory
that's that's that's an artist oh boy
like one of your French girls
I got an alert what's up hahaha just a stupid
like a fantasy maybe I will bust your jaw you
want to bust your job I'm sorry it's not what
wow you [__] creep my life it's pure fantasy
I got mixed up oh you got mixed up it's just so
beautiful oh my God wrong choice of words yeah
every step of the way I don't have anything
you got it all and you don't even care I care
plenty your wife is a lonely woman now crossing
the line home yeah unappreciated unsatisfied
untouched oh yeah I won't put you
through this God Walk you're crossing
the line you don't know what you've
got I know it damn well interview
go back and be the most passionate
I'm gonna wreck that painting
and we'll know it's him yep
or it's an act did you vote for him no I
did not pose for him show him your body
of course not did he touch
you no did you touch him oh
my God he drew you're naked in his quarters up
there on board I don't know what he drew he draws
from memory that's what I was worried about it you
knew I didn't want him here anymore you never said
I told you he hit our son and you did
not listen to me you didn't listen
told him directly about this inappropriate
behavior he thinks that you're lonely
all the time you're here I'm lonely oh
boy they're having a real conversation
you brought me here put me in this house now
I just walk from room to room but you're a
shadow and I am here I am real so no he
didn't touch me but I wished he did I oh
point of no return for a moment it
felt like my husband was back and he
he and I wished he did too by he
he means you're yeah go to her
oh
you gotta start talking boy I wanted to apologize
nothing happened with Lana I know she wasn't
interested uh uh well that's true that hurts
buddy I'm lonely you don't know what
it's like I just want to say goodbye
a con man the worst kind The Arrogant
kind she won't have you anywhere near her
it's mine for all time she is
mine he's just very disturbing
no he's gonna kill your ass you would
not see or speak to her ever again oh
oh no he's gonna kill him damn it some kind
of emergency all your emergencies are fake
what is it a small impact a few minutes ago cool
and tubing took ahead sleeping pretty bad it's
random out there God damn it dude no visible
signs of damage David he sure is cool in four
God damn it David
you should have like a code word
with your wife yeah safe word
huh where the hell are you bathroom
where's my tag my tag
put it back
he sabotage it what now nobody gets to use
oh no Jesus Christ what did you do
oh
[Music]
no no no no
please let this be like you wanted him to
feel like you've just did painting it's
just alizarin Crimson everybody don't worry I
hope he's just trying to make a point enough
oh no he actually did it
oh
whoa [Music]
oh and that same spinning hot head
shot too the bookends tragedy bookends
yeah you want him to experience it
[Applause]
what I can't just end like that [Laughter]
truly alone together
wow I was messed up interesting yes I was [Music]
really well done because it kept going the route
that you would expect it to go and then
right before it across that line there we go
and then we're going a different way yeah like
every single time it you know like right down to
the whole thing with the uh affair with not the
affair but kind of yeah uh with it with the wife
with the painting and yeah getting all clothes
you just never you're like oh he's gonna hijack
his butt he does it's like I did not see that
coming where he would murder them in the end yeah
I mean the guy's just so try like just went
too far he's he's completely traumatized and
also like as detached as one could possibly become
yeah it was uh just said he's just holding on to
the fantasy as the one thing giving him hope yeah
cracks truly truly a lesson in in Hope sometimes
being more cruel maybe now you'll appreciate
everything wow that was amazing that was that
was so transportive what an experience that was
a movie yeah it really was this is a couple is
his length of a movie yeah that's a real film
right there it has all like all the atmosphere
and all the yeah just breath of a film I wish it
had it didn't have the open-ended foreign like
an open-ended ending I like when things have an
open-ended conclusion but it doesn't I don't know
I was like oh I want to know that he killed him he
certainly should kill him he probably should but
it's like Josh hartnett's become so dangerous
he did that so fast yeah yeah it's like he
he could only have been out there for I mean it it
must have been a minute but it wasn't like an hour
it doesn't seem like it seems like it was like
15 or 20 minutes he was out there yeah if that
and yeah the acting was so amazing from everyone
here superb Aaron Paul playing dual roles here
really able to distinguish it without her feeling
he's doing a Josh hartnet impression Josh Hartnett
going from that All-American astronaut into this
Hollow Man Who Would seemed like it'd seemed like
he's weak when he's in spike in space and it
becomes like just the monster by the end yeah
um yeah I love the aesthetic the landscape I
love how they chose to make it with the 60s at
the time of masculinity especially for men like
this where emotions were so much more detail like
where the ability to not really identify how
you're feeling can just consume you and I love the
the the feigning of man who really is in
tune with his emotions with Josh Hartnett
but he's really not obviously
yeah you know not for real yeah
oh wow that was that was wild that was that was
so wild it was so it was like such a simple movie
it was a simple it was simple well because it's
so so complicated yeah it's it's so human and
I do appreciate like you said yeah that they
kind of let things just unfold in what feels
like a very gradual sort of sensory sort of
way and yeah it flirts with all the things
you're expecting and it does a couple of
them and I don't know yeah there's such a
I don't know it felt like it
had this like nicely sort of
sophisticated tone because it's yeah it's like
it's not pulpy but it does have just like this
constant sense of dread and ominousness and
just like something is wrong yeah and you're
just watching in like Advanced slow motion this
this horrible circumstance get worse and yeah
like I too I appreciate the way they draw the
characters because your sympathies and your
you know identifications drift and you know you
obviously meet them in a way that demonstrates
yeah Josh Hartnett is you know certainly the
more gregarious social type and Aaron Paul
is very closed off uh and then I don't know yeah
it's like it didn't really ever feel cliche like
there's an easily cliche version of this that they
could have gone down and you know it does a lot of
things that you would expect but just not in the
way or with the tone you would it doesn't ever
devolve into being like a silly mellow drama like
it does feel like this harsh confusing situation
and when he's like breaking down uh the David
character he's like I have nothing in this world
any longer I'm basically I'm alone up here with
you you know on this Mission we're just continuing
to drift out into Oblivion and like yeah you you
can fathom away in which this almost could work
and it had especially given the time and place
that's in it like it just yeah seems like a
complete recipe for disaster born of an attempted
altruism which is so tragic and so horrible
that was gratifying yeah and I added like
again we've said it but like hats off to the
performances so much because too like I it was
nice surprise to see Josh Hartnett back and see
him you know in a in a really you know juicy role
like this but also like Aaron Paul like I I love
Aaron Paul and for some reason I always have like
this same like process when I see him in something
new I'm like oh yeah you know it's Aaron Paul
I'm gonna see kind of Aaron Pauling it when I
really jump into whatever the thing is you know
it's easy to think of like Aaron Paul and Jesse
but like he's so good at embodying very different
characters and just in going through the spectrum
of emotion and what feels like such a natural like
when he's breaking down in the woods it was like
such a beautiful unbroken take of that and uh and
yeah he always impresses me and at the outset I'm
always like I'm gonna like him in it but you know
I'm gonna be aware of Tim and then you know he'll
slip into these roles in ways I I don't expect and
I think that's really impressive and Kate Mara too
I thought she she did a really nice job kind
of being in this horribly unfortunate position
between the both of them and yeah it's like you're
in some ways you're rooting for Cliff but Cliff is
also like not the best guy so like you see how
David is the better match in a lot of ways and
Cliff clearly does care but yeah he just doesn't
have touch or access to his emotional Spectrum
enough at all to really kind of make good on that
and yeah it's like it's just such a tragic story
from every possible angle and then finally at
the very end it gets you know super Twisted again
and even that a whole bit with a Manson
the Manson gang at the top was gnarly
but uh yeah it's like it's it's
funny because it's such a again
such a naturalistic such a I know we name
checked uh Terence Malik it has that sort
of like tactile life thing about it and yet it
feels like very sci-fi at the same time even
though the Sci-Fi the like the physical
sci-fi elements are like pretty grounded
those are my favorite kind of Black Mirror
episodes when it's not really about explaining
a technological thing that they're watching The
Human Experience and the association and how it
[__] with your mind based off of the connection
that you form with the technology so even though
this is not necessary like it's a play on the on
the Avatar thing you know yeah uh which I feel
like one day they'll be able to develop something
like that which I feel like would be really cool
um but I I think having like the that as I call
family was very much like uh the Manson family for
sure like that's exactly what they were going for
there and the Culkin prep that was it was you know
Severance is that the shortest time it's not that
Culkin I don't think it's it's a difference yeah
I think it's a lot shorter yeah it's uh I don't
know that I yeah he's one of the coke yeah yeah
another Culkin with another very culkiny name well
they're smart to really let that feel insanely
disturbing like the effect of that uh just you're
you're left with the impact to constantly have you
sympathize for Josh hartnett's character so much
to the point that even when he's crossing the line
you're like you're across in the library there's
always this is how to do this like but dude
I I understand why your your psyche has led
you down this path yeah yeah you gotta reel
it in but then when Aaron Paul starts going
off on him they were like dude like yeah why
you're so mad you gotta get this guy you've
got one hour yeah a week yeah and you get to
spend all this time there yeah and he's he's been
through hell and back and you have no idea what
he's had to do and he's just like this this love
these kind of men are constantly about having to
put on the display of composure at all times even
when they're in their most frail fragile States
in their life they have to just maintain some
level of everything's all right when it's not
um and like when he's going off at him in the
end you're like damn it we were so close to
just having some kind of strange resolve
but then you shattered him there it's like
you wanted to hurt him yeah so bad when you
know it's like like no amount of break they
get allows them to have any sort of refl like
reflection or understanding of what the other
person is like they you lose such sight of that
so if I loved how the human the portrayals were
of the of these men yeah that their flaws get the
best of them in every way Aaron Paul specifically
like starting off as a person
is like very understanding and
because like yeah Josh Hartnett takes advantage
of him in every way because he literally lends
him his body to be able to have an external
thing he didn't have to do and then he's going
out there saying like you're he's not man enough
for you and all that because dealing with reality
is too tough you know this is a story of a
man who does who cannot successfully grieve
and when it was like that there's the biggest fear
moment to me was when Aaron Paul like unloaded on
him at the very end yeah and it's like my wife
says that she makes her vomit the thought of you
um because too much yeah you're like God I know
what he did was like he crossed the line but yeah
one party is like understanding it oh like across
the line put yourself in this case because they do
these nice nuanced touches with getting you to
understand the kind of manner and Paul is with
being closed off and like also the whole thing
about like hitting the sun like you never see it
you never see him like actually hit the
key you never see this kid once get hit
but even when Josh Hartnett when embodying Aaron
Paul's body you know hits the kid even Aaron
Paul's like understanding of that like you've got
to keep that kid in line you got to keep that kid
in line like you get the idea of the mentality of
this kind of who this man is and you'd think that
Aaron Paul would be softer like we're going to
move to the countryside we're going to isolate
ourselves and he and he speaks softly to his wife
you know but you see that there is this violent
guy in him okay this possessive guy and while Josh
Hartnett is like the bigger guy you know like when
Aaron Paul's like standing up to him like that
speaks to the prowess of Aaron Paul's performance
where when he's getting in Josh harnett's face
you believe that Josh Arnett is like scared yeah
he's like intimidated by him because he's in such
a weak state that you wouldn't actually expect him
to cross the line to such a violent path of that
Recreation and also punishment for being hurt so
bad that he really feels like you know you're just
not deserving of this and and how painful it was
what kmar did but I love the way the way they
handled the kmar situation because she easily
could have been exactly the affair woman you know
like like I said it just keeps going down like we
both said it just keeps going down the path of
where you expect it to go and then the second
they start going to that line they shift course
you know the second they start actually he starts
getting touchy feely with her and like you know
breathing on her neck she's tempted by it and then
she walks away from the situation never gives into
the situation again and she stands up to him and
says like you manip you're being manipulative you
were trying to shower me with gifts and trying to
get into my my mind and heart when you are just
taking advantage of a situation right now like
they made her someone very mature in this versus
what most things would do which is exactly what
I thought they were gonna do yeah you know they
kept saying like this is where it's going this
is where it's going she's going to sleep with this
guy it's gonna get sexual I'm gonna have an affair
and maybe Josh Arnett's gonna take over his body
yeah yeah I mean you know you think it's going
more that direction and the way they have her hold
her ground as a strong woman like allowing her to
have her flaws and you know allowing her to have
her moments of weakness with temptation but then
giving her giving giving you an understanding of
where she's coming from with that scene that she
has in Aaron Paul Barn where she is lamenting
all of her emotions and he's actually finally
listening to her for the first time I thought
was such a nuanced scene because you know they
established so much that he's willing to like
he's willing to hit someone you know and like he's
probably gonna hit her he's probably gonna hit her
right now yeah and he doesn't instead he listens
you know so in some ways what Josh Harnett did was
the path to them healing the relationship and then
he just [__] it up he went two weeks way too far
yeah it's like he illuminated all the things that
you're missing and yeah I love the way he played
that because it's almost like yeah the kind of
guy that Aaron Paul that character is you kind of
believe like oh I guess you would just be capable
of missing what your wife is clearly expressing
through her demeanor through this entire situation
and uh yeah I like to as much as you know
part of you wants the satisfaction of like
kill him man at the same time I like the
way they draw the scenario in space because
it does seem like it's a two-man Mission and
if you know unless both of us are going to
perish we need the two of us up here and now it's
like there's nothing else so it is kind of like
a question mark of just like the human survival
Instinct now and they are like bonded in the worst
way possible and that actually kind of tickles
my imagination a little bit because I I yeah
and part of me is like he could easily kill him
and he's got nothing else to live for so they'll
just both die but I could also see how like in a
Twisted way maybe they just won't kill each other
and we'll just see this Mission out and just be
damaged and Beyond damaged forever yeah and yeah
just I don't know the depth of depravity like yeah
the the true break within that David character is
something fascinating because two it's like they
both get objectified in the in the traditional way
you think look sexual but like the whole family
is like this object because Aaron Paul is yelling
like they're my like mine like the way he yells at
that one particular time really feels like a yeah
like you would yell about a thing you own and by
the end you know the David character does the same
thing he he uses them as a device to communicate
his perspective and it's just so sad and terrible
because yeah it's like they're also just
regular people you know being maimed by a robot
thanks yeah well and the other thing
we haven't talked about too is how the
one of the things about when you're in space
is like one of the things they train like with
astronauts a lot and especially these the crazy
missions is it's mainly a psychological game and
I love how even though they have the accessibility
to go back to Earth if the Via these replicas
you still get that touch and Sensibility of the
Mind drifting in the mind losing itself insanity
you know yeah well and it almost begs again it
begs that question of Hope because on the one
hand you're like what a beautiful advancement this
would be amazing you know if you could just plug
back into Earth and yeah like have a direct link
to your Humanity but then if anything goes wrong
that could be absolutely catastrophic and cause
even greater psychological damage than if you
were just under the circumstance that you're up
here and you're isolated and that's life for the
foreseeable future yeah it's like giving you the
access makes it worse when it goes away and even
worse when it goes away terribly and so it is like
a fascinating question because I think anybody
would be like yeah if we had the capability
to do that absolutely but at the same time
I don't know like even though it is maybe one
of the more heightened parts of the episode
like yeah you'll have people who are like this is
an Abomination and setting it in the 60s I think
makes that bit work it's like if it had been
modern day I don't think as many people would
be apt to like you know Manson up and go kill the
Abomination robot you know automaton uh but here
you know in the time and place it does seem to
make you know it's it rings truer of a Time less
demystified by crazy Tech and you have this one
kind of magic element which is the replica and uh
it's yeah that's the stuff to me that gets kind
of at the Twisted core of you know what makes a
Black Mirror because you know this is clearly one
of the more like lyrical more Moody more again
Airy episodes I feel like they've done a couple
like even though it's not like tonally similar it
kind of reminded me of uh I feel like San ju pero
kind of has a similar quality even that one even
though that one's more like uh less sad but yeah
like this this core twistedness that just feels
so Bleak and and sad but also like human human
despite how you know technological it is I guess
dark depths of the human core yeah quite
an ethereal experience ladies and gentlemen
that was fun yeah it's fun and all the most
messed up it messed me up I'm very much uh
I think it's gonna be the last one we shoot today
on my brains my brain's not just wife from this I
had we shot the first one and then I had to like
edit and do the thumb and upload I was like I kind
of took the window now and now we should watch
this I was like wow my mind's just messed up
well yeah it's one of those episodes that ends
in your life yeah I just kind of want to sit in
silence and contemplate I'm like how terrible my
soul feels right now the whole time I was like
how do I feel right now because I I don't know
how I film on this weird Vortex of a situation
because because there's so many it's sewn layered
in nuanced with so many vast emotions it's such
a wide array at unlike on every frame of this
episode that like oh man my my I I am watching
this way at the wrong hour after after a very
long day yeah go hop in the Pod and take it out
I gotta talk about this this is really hard yeah
yeah the hardest time talking about is [Music]
um but that was that was beautiful yeah
that was great that was that was amazing
beautiful it was truly amazing that's
what's one for the books Unforgettable
um all right guys well thanks for
being here and we will um soon [Music]